We are excited to have our speaker finale.
Doshi Vela is here today.
She is an assistant professor in computer
science at the Harvard Paulson School
of Engineering and Applied Sciences.
Her research focuses on the intersection
of machine learning and healthcare and
today she'll be speaking to us about
interpretability towards more rigorous
rigorous evaluation.
Thank you.
Hi everyone.
It's
exciting to be here. Um, I like
to keep talks fairly informal,
so if you have questions along
the way, please shout out. Um,
and we'll also have questions toward the
end. I one to, I want to point out, um,
I'm going to share a little bit if the
work that we're doing currently in our
group, but more importantly, uh, the,
the thing that I want to chat about is
how we can make interpretability more
rigorous.
So it's a bit this,
this talk is going to have
more of a philosophical or
forward looking component,
um,
rather than a ton of results that
are already completed components.
And that's why I encourage everyone,
if you have ideas to like really engage
in the discussion because that's what
I'm really interested in having.
So just to get started,
um, as a, you wouldn't be
here if you weren't interested
in interpretability. Um,
it's definitely in vogue,
tons of publications coming
out, especially lately.
Um,
if you just look at Google scholar hits,
obviously the rate of publications
in general has been increasing,
but you see there's huge
numbers of publications in
the last several years, um,
under this guise of interpretability
in machine learning.
And part of that interest comes from the
fact that machine learning systems are
being deployed in more and more settings
and as part of more and more systems
and now we are curious about,
well,
are these system's behaving
in ways that we expect? Sorry,
they latching on to signals
that we didn't expect.
How can we ensure that our systems are
doing what we want them to do and how can
we debug them when they're not doing
things that we want them to do?
Hence this growing interest
in interpretability. Um,
but the big question is what
exactly is interpretability?
And that's the thing that
I want to chat about today.
And also how should we
go about quantifying and
measuring it both from a human
perspective and also is there a way to
distill it down so that we can optimize
for interpretability maybe without
all of those expensive human subject
evaluations.
That's it.
Those are the sorts of things that
we're gonna be chatting about. So first,
let's start out with this question
of what is interpretability.
So if you look at a dictionary
definition of the word interpret,
which is the root word
for interpretability,
it's to give or provide
meaning to explain.
And I think that explanation is actually
a much more like human tangible word
than interpretability, right? It's,
it's easier to think about
what is a good explanation.
Have I explained something to you?
Because you can think about whether,
do you understand it or not?
All right,
so that's the term that I'm really going
to be thinking of and I'm encouraging
you all to think about when you think
of EC interpretability is the question,
what's the quality of this explanation?
And before I go forward,
I also want you distinguish the word
interpretability or the process of
providing explanation from a lot of
other words that we also see as auxiliary
criteria for our machine learning systems.
So there,
there was a time when we were
just interested in prediction.
So we just need a system to predict
and now we're often interested in other
criteria as well.
So there's been a lot of recent interest
in transparent systems in accountable
systems, trustable systems, fair systems,
systems that produce actionable outputs,
systems that are robust or
reliable systems that are safe.
And some of these areas I forgot,
privacy, privacy is another one. Um,
so there,
there's a lot of these sorts of terms
that are being bandied about and some of
them like privacy,
they have very clear there are some
at least attempt at making a rigorous
definition.
For example,
differential privacy has a very clear
mathematical formalism. You can, I,
you can verify whether a system
is differentially private or not.
And we don't have that
in interpretability.
And one of my goals is to get us closer
to thinking about what those sorts of
definition should be.
The reason I distinguish the process of
explanation from these other criteria is
it oftentimes we fall back
on interpretability or
the need for explanation
because some of these other criteria are
also not particularly well quantified.
So we want us to send to be safe.
For example,
what if we can't list out all the
situations in which an unsafe, uh,
scenario might happen, we
might fall back on, well,
if the system can at least
explain what it's doing,
then we're in a good position to identify
whether something might be safe or
unsafe with a bit of human checking.
Right?
So interpretability is this
thing that you do mostly in the,
probably in the service of something
else, right? So let's, let's, uh,
let's actually think about what reasons
you might need for interpretability.
So one area that I work in
quite a bit is in healthcare.
So we are interested in
deriving disease subtypes.
We are also interested in identifying
what treatments work best for what
patients.
And in this case there is
a clear scientific question
of like what is disease,
how does it progress, how to drugs
interact with a disease process.
And interpretability is really important
because we are looking at large amounts
of data.
But at the end of the day we actually
want to have some new insights about the
mechanism of human physiology
and pathophysiology.
Another reason why you might
want interpretability is
to be able to debug your
system. You have no idea why
the system is not working.
But if the system can give you an
explanation of how it's coming to its
decisions,
maybe you can identify why that decision
is wonky and find the the issue in the
system. I also met, I already
mentioned the issue of safety. Again,
maybe you can't identify all the scenarios
under which a system might be unsafe,
but at least if it tells you under at any
point what you might want to do or why
it's making a decision,
you can decide whether what you want to
do with that decision. Another big area,
um, category that I put a
here is mismatched objectives.
So,
going back to the clinical scenario,
sometimes we have a thing that
we're interested in terms of output.
So for example,
if you have a patient who is depressed
and you want to manage their depression,
then that's the criteria and maybe
that you're trying to optimize.
But it might also be the case that
that patient is averse to weight gain.
And so there might be this auxiliary or
secondary objective that you were not
aware of,
or maybe there's a particular drug that
requires being taken three times a day
versus a drug that being taken once a day.
And depending on the patient,
the probability of adherence may be
different for those two regimens.
And if you have those written out,
then maybe you could write them all
down and you could put them into an
objective function or just solve the
multi objective problem. You can,
we know how to find Paredo fronts when we
have multiple objectives, right? Again,
there's no interpretability
required there. Um,
but if we don't actually have the full
objective at the time and maybe the human
is not even aware of
exactly what they want,
then that you have run into this case
of mismatch objectives where you need a
little bit of explanation that
might suggest why this was chosen,
but maybe you can also decide that you
want to do something else. Um, and,
and change the,
the final decision.
And the final one that I'm going
to point out is in a legal setting.
So EU regulation is going to require all
systems algorithmic systems to provide
explanation starting in 2018 2019.
And I think we as a community,
as computer scientists, as people who
are interested in interpretability,
have a real opportunity here to
make sure that that regulation,
like the definition of that is
going to be decided in courts,
but we need to be able to come up
with proposals of what we think
interpretability should been and what
the reasonable definition should be.
Otherwise it's going to be decided for us.
Right?
So there's kind of a pressing need here
from a legal perspective to come up with
operational definitions
of interpretability.
So in all of these cases that I described,
I would say the common thread is that
there's a fundamental incompleteness in
the problem specification.
And I want to distinguish that from the
concept of uncertainty. For example,
if you are trying to track a
missile on a radar, you know the,
the radar does not exactly
pick up where the missile is.
There's going to be some uncertainty and
you have this ellipse about where you
think the missile is.
You get your set of measurements
and it decreases your uncertainty.
Or maybe it increases it because
it's something unexpected.
And now maybe you can turn on different
kinds of radar and you can use that to
determine further hone your estimates.
But this is a closed system, right?
You have a set of measurements and you
can very well quantify the uncertainty,
right? So in that sense, the
problem specification is uncertain,
but it's not incomplete.
And to the end of the day,
you're going to have to make a
decision with that uncertainty.
And we have rigorous ways of
decision making under uncertainty.
That's an entire branch of cs so that
if you're living in that scenario,
you don't really need interpretability.
There's no human in the loop necessary
required because at the end of the day,
you're just going to have to make
the best decision you can given the
uncertainty that you have and the
examples that I've described here.
In contrast,
you have this fundamental incompleteness.
There's no way around the fact that
if you are trying to create scientific
hypotheses,
you don't know exactly what you're
looking for and you need some sort of
explanation to help you
generate those hypotheses.
Or if you cannot write down all of your
safety scenarios in terms of unit tests,
then you need the explanation.
There is a fundamental thing
that you can just cannot,
you cannot unit test your way out of
this, um, particular situation. Right. So,
so that's one thing to
keep in mind because I,
I guess there's various debate about
whether interpretability is needed or when
it is needed.
And this is the definition that I like
to stick with or reasoning that I like to
stick with in terms of
fundamental incompleteness.
So before I go into talking a
little bit more about, um, uh,
ways to measure interpretability,
I'm just going to give you a little
teaser or a taste of the sorts of things
that we're doing in our group. Just one
little short Vignette, a little story. Um,
uh, so this is work that is, was
just accepted to Itch Chi, um,
which we are calling right for the
right reasons. And here's, I mean,
here's the main idea. Um, so we have,
let's say we're interested in
creating some sort of different,
we have a differentiable Cli
classifier such as neural network.
And so we have some set of
outputs and we have some inputs.
And what,
again,
the choice of this function can be
anything like a neural network. Um,
and then we have some set of
weights that it's parameterized by.
And then if we have that,
uh, the question could be,
are there multiple qualitatively different
classifiers and why it might be we
interested in that.
Well,
maybe there's these reasons over here
where one of them might be unsafe or it
might not be reliable.
Um,
it may be the case that one has some
subtle subtle issue with it due to a
confounder.
And so without the information
of why it's making the decision,
um, we, we can't tell
for those sort of things.
But if a classifier can tell you why
it's making the decision and we can find
multiple classifiers who make the
same decision for different reasons,
then maybe we can try to give those to
someone and have them decide which is the
best one,
which is the one that they like.
And maybe just exposing the fact that
there's multiple different ways to get the
same level of prediction accuracy with
different types of classifiers is also
kind of enlightening to them about the
nature of the Dataset that you have on
hand.
Uh,
the way we do this is we're going to
define our explanations in terms of the
gradient.
So if you tried to change your
value of the input by a little bit,
remember that x is the input.
If you change the value of
the input by some amount,
how much does the output change?
Um,
so if you have an input
that is very sensitive to,
then that is something that should be
upgraded and your explanation or be part
of your explanation.
Um,
whereas if it's something where changing
this x doesn't really change your
output,
then maybe it's not an important feature.
So ingredients have been used as a form
of explanation. This is not new to us.
It had been proposed as a form
of explanation in the past.
And the Nice thing about
these is that they're,
they do rely on derivatives
and derivatives are very
easy for us to compute.
They're very fast compared to
perturbation based approaches.
So there's a lot of other approaches
such as Lyme that take the x,
perturb the x,
and see what perturbations of x
result in the biggest changes in why.
I said it's another way of doing
your sensitivity analysis through to
perturbations. We're doing that now. An
infinitesimal scale with derivatives.
The advantage being that they're,
again, they're super fast.
And now what we can do is we can say,
if you're given one set of weights,
let's find a different set of weights
that are not allowed to use the gradients
that we're large in the next round.
So round one you create
your own classifier round
to either someone provides
some annotations and say's
actually these were bad,
like don't use this information when
making this decision or you just try to
find a completely different
solution. Right. Um,
so I'm just going to give you,
again, this is a short story,
so I'm just going to give you some
examples of how this sort of system might
work. So here we have an example where
we're trying to classify these images,
these five by five images
into two categories.
And the choice of the category
can be made in two different ways.
So it can be made depending on whether
the corners of the square match in color
or not.
Uh,
and it can also be made based on whether
these top three elements of the square
match or not.
And so there's two different ways of
doing the classification that are going to
lead you to exactly the same
classification accuracy. So the, the,
in the first round, uh,
the of the class of Arthur,
this is accuracy in the first round of
the classifier. Um, we're doing it again,
this is a simple classification problems.
So you get a hundred percent performance
and it's mostly picking out these
corners.
Second round we say you're not allowed
to use the information that was highly
weighted in the first round.
Find me a completely different
classifier or as best as you can,
you have a parameter that you can tune.
And so the second round,
while there is actually another example
that exists, another choice that exists.
So it gives you that choice out here.
And then you go to the third round and
you say, actually, now I want one more.
Can you, can you do it for me? Um,
and it tries and it's mostly
picking up noise and the,
the accuracy goes down. So this,
this is a very simple approach,
very fast approach. Because again,
it's just based on gradients,
competing gradients, twice. Essentially.
You need to be able to take your function,
differentiate it,
and then you need to differentiate again
to be able to compute sensitivity to
the input gradients.
But that's all you need to do.
And then we can do this on
more complicated setting.
So here we played a similar
game with two UCI data sets,
Iris and breast cancer.
And what we did is we took the outputs
and we glued together examples from these
two different data sets
based on the outputs.
So if it's like flour of
type A and tumor of type B,
those are all get linked together
concatenated together. So now again,
there's two rules for making the decision.
And here what we find is that this
is much more complicated dataset.
There's many ways in which you can,
so here iterations,
there's actually many ways you can get
very good prediction accuracy and this
isn't going to useful thing to keep in
mind that from any real world data sets
this happens. Um, but you see that the
test accuracy test accuracy, there you go,
um, is lower sometimes because
it's picking up. So in the,
this was in the training and then
in the tests that we took away,
basically the flower information,
like we permuted the labels.
So the right thing to focus on
was the cancer tissue question.
So initially you see that it had
picked up on the wrong stuff.
And as you go through fewer,
as you go through additional iterations,
it ends up picking up on the right things.
And there's no guarantee that this is
going to happen in that particular order.
But the ability to be
able to produce quickly,
qualitatively different solutions helps
you sift through them and try to find
ones that are reasonable.
And this is the last example
I'll give you along these lines.
So here we have an example
from 20 newsgroups and uh,
these are examples of words that
it's picking out, uh, in different,
in different iterations. So this is, uh,
being able to distinguish the
atheism and Christianity threads,
which was used in previous papers, uh,
on interpretability. Hence we chose it.
Um, you, what you see
again is that there's many
classifiers that have reasonable
performance.
Um,
and you see that the test performance
varies quite a bit depending on the
different choices of classifiers.
Cause like sometimes they end up picking
up weird confounds in the data. This,
this data set has a lot of strange
confounds that you can pick up on because
sometimes the person posting their name
actually be ends up being like a really
key signal and on and all sorts of things.
And the point here is that in this,
so this is a much more real setting.
You might not know what the right one is,
but at least you can cut,
you can skim through the factors
that are being used and look at um,
the prediction performances. And you
can decide, you can say, you know,
I really just don't like that classifier.
I want a different one.
And you can keep asking it
to produce different ones.
So this is just an example of the sort
of things that we do in our group where
we're interested in creating these sorts
of systems that assist in projects that
are ultimately going to require a human.
Because there is a fundamental in
completeness in the problem specification.
We know that the data that
we have is not enough.
The data combined with the
problem specification that
we have is not enough that
a system can just solve this problem
on its own, right. There's going to be,
have to be some sort of interaction and
because there's going to be some sort of
interaction,
we need to be able to provide a,
what is it useful things for us to do.
It's useful for us to provide explanation
is useful for us to provide multiple
explanations. Cool. So
let's now go back to,
um, the, the evaluation question. Yup.
First,
with this work,
have you looked at reading and
stone bowls with these different,
so, so the question was, have we looked
at creating ensembles of these networks?
And one could certainly do,
so I guess we've been in the mindset
that some of these are going to be right
for the wrong reasons and we just
wouldn't want to use them at all because
they're,
they're going to pick up on a confounder.
But certainly you could use this to
create just more robust decision makers,
like a way to propose an ensemble
that you could then do, stir,
do whatever you want it
are questions. Yup. Yeah. Any one of the
interpreter.
So this is, we didn't do a user
study, but just among ourselves. Um,
there were definitely ones that
made a lot of sense. I mean,
so the first one is essentially picking
out words like Christian and atheism.
It seems very reasonable for the
classification task at hand. Um,
some of the later ones end up with names
of people and we could look at those
and say these are clearly not
making sense because it was,
they were picking up
users and such like this
Qca or something.
Same thing.
There might be one in your room.
So, uh, the, the,
the comment was some of the axes end up
being interpretable and some of them may
be less interpretable. Um, and so
the, the, that, that's a fair point.
And one thing that we're working on now
is can we at least limit the number of
things that are sensitive to so you can
at least look at them and so not only
give us multiple cloud
qualitatively different classifiers,
but can you produce a classifier that
for any test point is going to give you a
succinct explanation and that's something
that we're actively working on right
now and is relatively easy to build into
the loss function because now you want
to say that the input gradient should
not be large but for more than a certain
number of elements for every
input and for different inputs.
You may allow different things to be
important, but for any particular input,
we only want a few things to be important
and this is something that you can
again easily put into this framework.
I'm just trying to understand it.
When you say you do a first pass,
you find some classifier,
this seems to work and you say,
oh, I don't like that classifier.
It's fight for the wrong reason.
I'm just curious,
does that mean it's not really right,
like it's not predictive or it's
predictive, but for some policy reason,
I don't want to use it.
It's predictive, but first some
policy reason I don't want to use it.
And the one example could be that,
let's say that it's picking
up a confound in the data set.
So there's this really popular example
and the interpretability world,
if this wolf where says Huskey the
wolves are usually out in nature scenes.
The huskies are usually like an
indoor scenes and so you could build a
classifier and say's if there's a tree
in the picture, it's probably a wolf.
And that's a classifier that on your
data will do really well because your
data's had happened to have this bias
in it that you were not aware of.
And so that's an example of where
you might want to throw that away.
And you might want to say that that's
actually not the explanation that I want.
I want a different one.
So in some sense,
are you repairing the specification
that you gave the AML system?
You said optimize this, it did it did
it correctly and now you're just saying,
oh no, I didn't want to use that.
I didn't properly specify it.
I meant find wolves independent
of whether or not there are trees.
Exactly. It's not so, so it, right.
So you hit it right on the head.
But I think the case where you need
interpretability is where the problem,
there's something wrong
with the specification. Yup.
That was, and that's a
question I'm trying to get to.
I'm just trying to understand.
So I understand that task,
which is for policy reasons, I don't
want to use that. Yes, that classifier.
But now I'm trying to connect back
to the title of the talk around
interpretability, which is the classifier
was doing its job and if I had to,
if I just had to explain what
it was doing, I could say,
Oh yes and here's why I find that it
used the tree. Yes. Right. Or you know,
it used this blood test to decide this
treatment or use this factor to decide
the credit worthiness of this
European Union resident or something.
It was doing an accurate, it was
solving the problem. I just, for a Po,
I'm trying to decide which is it that
we wanted select a different set of,
of Mol Program is for,
for policy reasons and which is it,
we want to know what they're doing.
So is it we want to understand them or
is it we we only want to use certain
types of,
right. So, so the focus of this
talk is going to be around the, the,
the definition and the evaluation
of interpretability. And this, this,
this is a short vignette to explain just,
just to make concrete,
like I gave a bunch of reasons why
you want might want interpretability.
So this is an example of a task where
you wanted interpretability to be able to
check whether the classifier was making
its decisions for the right reasons and
be able to reject it if it was
making it for the wrong reasons.
So this is just an example of a situation
where you might want interpretability
but there are many.
And so we're going to move out.
We're going to zoom back out
into the general question. Uh,
and this was just one specific example
of a situation where you might want this
[inaudible].
All right. So, so the big
question is like in this case,
maybe you had someone in the loop,
right?
Maybe you had someone providing that
feedback about, I like this explanation.
I don't like this explanation. And you
had a system, right? You, you were,
that you were trying to build for
certain policy related task, right? But,
and so presumably if you
were trying to do that,
then you have a measure of how well it
works because you have a task in mind,
you have an expert in mind,
that expert can check and you can
can request additional solutions.
Okay.
But now let's think about it
more broadly, right? What,
how can you measure interpretability
okay.
In the APP, not necessarily any absence,
but in the abstract, right? In the,
in the more general sense. Uh,
so one option is to say, well,
interpretability it's like porn. You
know it when you see it. Um, and so it,
or this is a kind of
related way of saying it,
is that we have interpretability by Fiat,
right?
Or just going to call this
thing interpretable cause
we've just decided that
this thing is interpretable.
And so if we look at various,
and these are like really
good papers by the way,
so I'm not making fun of any of them.
But what I want to point out is that
you often see statements in machine
learning papers and I'm guilty of this
as well. Um, uh, of the form, you know,
certain type of model is a gold standard
for intelligibility. Um, you know, the,
our rationales are simply subsets of
words. You know, this is just saying like,
clearly this thing is interpretable,
right?
These sentences are just telling you
that of course this is the right way to
solve this problem.
And,
and the thing that when we read
this and it seems reasonable to us,
there is a face validity to this because
the whole point about interpretability
that didn't make sense to human beings.
We're all human beings.
So if this explanation kind of makes
sense to us, that is cool. Right? Um,
but at the same time, um, it doesn't
really let us go forward, right?
Because it gives us a set of
classes that are interpretable,
but then then what do we do with that?
Right?
We can just optimize within that class.
Um, right. So this is what I just
said. So we agree that this, you know,
a jam is an interpretable model
then than now the problem is done.
The interpretability problem
is sometimes it's done,
all we have to do is optimized yams.
Um,
but we want to make sure that there's
some evidence for these different forms of
models actually being interpretable.
Another way of doing this is saying that
interpretability has to be evaluated in
the context of an event, uh,
in terms of a real application.
So this goes back to my story earlier
that maybe you had this application in
mind where you were trying to separate
those news group posts or understand
different tumor types, or in my case, um,
predict meds for different patients.
And if you're trying to do this task,
you have a clear goal that you want to
avoid confounds and interpretability has
succeeded if it allows you to do the
higher level task. Right. There was,
there was some task in service of which
you needed the interpretability and the,
the HCI, the, the human factors.
Communities have definitely embraced
this sort of view. You know, the, the,
the airplane controls are good if it
allows the pilot to fly the plane safely,
right?
That's your ultimate criterion.
So this sort of criterion is useful
because it's, it's a real evaluation.
Our real problem,
like no one's trying to like make up
something and say clearly this form of
model is interpretable. Um, you have
hard evidence as to whether or not the,
the model is actually interpretable.
Um, but it may be costly,
um,
to perform those evaluations because you
have to do it in the context of a real
application.
And you might be curious about whether
or not to generalize is, for example,
the human factors community in aerospace
has spend a ton of effort trying to
understand how flight controls
should be set up, right?
There's a lot of really
great science behind that.
But now if I'm trying to build
some sort of other user interface,
what can I learn about the
airline flight controls?
Save for a, a self drive or
semi autonomous car. Right?
It's not necessarily clear exactly
how the transfer happens. Right.
And that's the part that maybe we want
to make a little bit more explicit.
Yeah.
So the question that we want to get to,
um, is it, are there more general proxies?
Um, and so, uh, things like
sparsity are often brought up.
People often cite this, um, seven
plus or minus two rule that says like,
how much can people hold in
cognitive memory. Um, there,
there may also be I ideas
of monitor unicity that, oh,
I can understand like something that if
I turned the dial, like my accelerator,
if I push on the accelerator,
I know I always go faster and that,
that kind of makes sense to me.
And if I'm going up a hill or there's
a bump in the road, maybe the,
the rate of acceleration
might be slightly different,
but at least I kind of understand it and
he pushed on the accelerator and then
my car, it will move forward or
increase in speed. So are there,
are there fundamental
notions here? Um, and again,
the nice thing about these sort of having
these sort of fundamental notions is
that as computer sciences, we can
optimize these things, right? We,
we love this because now it's
like a mathematical function
that we can work with.
Um,
but again,
the issue is we need to make sure that
it's evidence based that we need to be
able to understand where is
this assumption coming from?
Or is it just something that's reasonable
that looks reasonable to us or is it
something deeper? And this is
important. Um, not only just from a,
like a philosophical,
I care about science perspective,
but I think it's also important for
being able to make comparisons, right?
Like if something is just a little bit
sparser is it actually more useful for
some downstream task?
Okay.
So what I'm going to propose here
is a spectrum for evaluation.
So I'm going to split it into two pieces,
um,
in terms of quantitative and
qualitative forms of evaluation.
And I think the qualitative part do
that. Absolutely. Um, we eventually,
I'll probably want to live in this
space over here because then again,
we can optimize it on a computer,
but before we get to that stage,
we need to think about the other elements.
So there's a level of the
real application, right?
So that's the level that
I talked about that again,
you might be thinking of from a human
factor standpoint or from a HCI standpoint
and you can measure did we actually
improve some patient outcomes?
Or we can just ask scientists,
you know, did you like this?
Right? Was this helpful?
Again, we're measuring something in
the context of a real application. Um,
and then we can think of it one level
more abstractly. We could say, um,
it can people describe what factors
should be changed in order to change the
outcome, right. That seems like
a reasonable sort of question.
If the explanation I've provided
you is a good one, then you might,
you should be able to forward simulate
what might happen with counterfactuals.
And then you may also ask more
qualitative things about the model itself.
And then finally you have the level of
what I'm calling proxies are things that
we can think of in more very abstract
terms like functions. Um, you know,
are the feature sparse, does it
look reasonable? And, uh, my,
my claim is that we need to move in
this direction of real stuff should be
informing the, the functions that
we are using for optimization. Um,
and uh,
keeping in mind that as we go up the
chain there things are going to get more
specific.
So I think that the top layer and the
bottom layer are pretty clear to mo
probably a pretty familiar
comfortable to most people.
You can think about optimizing
for like l one regularly,
like sparsity that's like really
conceptually simple for us. Um,
we can also think of measuring,
you know,
whether patient outcomes improved or not.
And the,
the part that I think is
really understudied and I
think that we should all be
thinking about and investing in is really
understanding the glue between those,
which is the cognitive science layer.
So I'm going to talk about, um,
how we might think about this layer and
some specific hypotheses that I think
are useful for us to, to think
about as a community in the space.
So in terms of a general form for
human evaluation of explanation.
So here we have, um, uh, this
very specific question, right?
Did we improve patient outcomes?
Like what's the equivalent of that
for just quality of explanation?
And in this case we're not interested
in whether the explanation is correct,
right? So keep in mind that my explanation
for like any prediction could be,
um, you know, because because
the sky is blue, right?
And the thing is that explanation does
not provide, is not predictive at all,
but maybe it's easy, but it's still easy
for you to understand, right? Like you,
you understand what I'm saying
when I say, because this, you know,
I predicted this tumor type because
the sky is blue, right? Like you,
you can understand it.
It's very understandable.
And the reason why we're going to focus
on understanding is that the accuracy
part of an explanation is actually
very easy to quantify that.
If I have a classifier that
predicts malignant tumor
every time the sky is blue,
I can check that and see how
good a classifier that is. Right?
That's a quantitative thing that
I can check and therefore we,
it's not a complicated problem in
terms of evaluations, very easy to do.
The hard part is measuring whether the
explanation is good in terms of does it
allow it, does it convey some
sort of understanding, right?
This a human understand what
the person is talking about.
So in terms of a general form for a
human evaluation of explanation, um,
what we're proposing is being able to
evaluate some sort of counterfactual. So
if you ask the person, how do I
need to change the inputs, right?
What if I change the inputs,
um,
to change some predictions. So I have,
maybe I have a specific data point.
I want to change the output,
right?
What inputs do I need to change
to get the output to change?
That might be a very general sort
of question that I could ask.
I could also ask about the
internals of the system.
I could say actually the
input stays the same.
Is there an element of the explanation
that I would need to change in order to
get the system to predict some different
output? And finally I could say, uh,
we could also think about this mismatch
objective thing saying that it actually,
what would I need to change in the
criteria to be able to get a different
output, uh, of interest? Right?
So there's all sorts of
permutations of this,
but this gets to the fundamental
idea that's very common. I mean,
when you're in school, how do they
test you on whether, you know,
explanations work. It's like whether
you can predict things, right?
You do a science experiment and they ask
you now what's going to happen when you
mix chemical a with chemical B? Can you
tell me the formula that came out? Right?
So we're essentially asking humans to
be able to answer similar questions.
But now instead of grading the humans,
we're grading the system because if the
human can answer the question that it
means a system did a good job of
explaining whatever it's trying to do.
So now we can move on to some
specific hypotheses. And again, I'm,
I'm really curious to get people's
feedback and input and I think it's really
important for us as a community to be
thinking about this layer of cognitive
science, which is not really
well thought through. Um, and,
and so one hypothesis is that in Wa in
terms of being able to generalize tasks,
how certain covariates so we can
think about where is the fundamental
incompleteness and the problem. Is it
in the structure of the data, right?
Are there just weird,
um, confounds, um, eh,
that may also be in the inputs as well.
Is it in the reward functions?
Is it in the internal
features and maybe different,
all of those cases might
have different needs, right?
It's important for us to think about the
fact that interpretability might not be
a one, there might not be one thing
that is interpretable in all scenarios.
And the form of the explanation you need
may be different for different settings.
Um, another important
distinction is the scope. Like,
are we trying to understand
the full model? In many
science cases we are, right?
You have a big batch of data and I want
to understand what does this tell me,
this big batch of tea data.
Tell me about disease progression and
different subtypes and autism, right?
I'm not interested in
any particular patient.
I want to understand the overall trends.
So there's that level.
I'm trying to understand explanations
for the whole system. On the other hand,
if I need to make a decision
for a specific patient and say,
do I treat this patient with this drug,
then the form of explanation
I need may be very different.
And in particular the need of how quickly
the explanation must be utilized as
could be quite different in
these different scenarios.
I might be willing to spend a couple
of hours looking at the output of some
global science discovery sort of system
where it's like if there's something
that needs to be made, a decision
that needs to be made at the bedside,
maybe you only have on the order
of minutes, uh, or, or less,
two to properly understand it.
So this seems all very
reasonable. And what I, uh,
again I said this talk is going
to be a lot of philosophy.
I'm encouraging people to maybe think
about that as you're building your systems
and designing your systems and thinking
about what are the natural ways in which
you can bend these systems and think
about the different needs that are
associated with them.
The other hypothesis that I like to float
out there, um, and how people consider,
so a little more abstract
is that explanation actually
has two components of it
that we maybe can think about distinctly
indistinct in, uh, in separately.
So the first component,
mmm,
it's pretty light, uh, is structure.
So if we think about agents'
actions and outcomes, uh,
maybe we have some explanation
that say's that, um,
here a goes to B goes to c, right?
That's the form of my explanation,
my explanation to, and did ground
that into a specific example.
Maybe you give a vasopressor it constricts
blood vessels and increases blood
pressure.
So if I'm trying to increase blood
pressure and the system says give
vasopressors, this might be the
explanation that comes out, right?
And that explanation has a certain
structure which is a to B to c.
Yeah.
And it might have all sorts of different
forms and different structures here,
maybe more or less understandable,
right?
Here's where we might run into issues
of like if too many factors are involved
in this explanation, we
just can't follow it, right?
We can do those counterfactual reasoning.
Like if there was some
other factor going in here,
maybe we wouldn't be able to do the
reasoning about what would happen if
something else changed and
something else changed, et Cetera.
Maybe he's going to get too hard.
And maybe that's a fundamental
quantity about humans, right?
That there are certain types of these
structures that we can easily handle.
And there's other structures
that we can't handle. So if,
if we're in that regime, we can think
abstractly in terms of like a to B to c,
right?
There's another key component and that
other key component is thinking about the
cognitive chunks.
So that what,
when we ground each of these
variables and like a specific concept,
and here it's important to remember.
So there again this,
this offsite is seven
plus or minus two rule.
It's not seven plus or
minus two. Well, some,
well actually seven plus or minus two.
What is the question? So if I give you,
um, the, the acronym Caia,
is that one thing to you or is
that three letters that you know,
you have to remember?
It's probably one thing because
you have a concept for that.
It's the single item.
And so one thing that's really important
in these very large data sets is first
identifying what are the cognitive chunks.
So clinicians might have a word
for a collection of diseases.
We work with billing codes a lot and
billing codes are like insanely specific.
And so you may how 25 or 30 codes
that exact correspond to epilepsy.
And so if the clinician has
a word for epilepsy, so,
so an explanation does not need to,
we don't need a separate a and a B and a
c out to some large fraction for all of
the different forms of epilepsy. We
could collapse it into one thing, right?
Similarly,
um,
we may have situations where certain
relationships might be really well known.
For example,
a vasopressor I'm constricting blood flow
blood vessels that that might be known
science. Right. So, so
the, the question was, um,
if you end up providing a
more succinct explanation, um,
but there were multiple fat that
only pulls out the biggest factors,
what about all the multiple other tiny
factors that that may also be affecting
the explanation and do you have
an ethical reason to expose them?
I think that's very problem dependent.
For example,
if you just want to be able to overall
be able to say like if changing none of
those factors is going to
change the outcome, uh, the,
the final prediction, maybe it's
safe to ignore them. If those final,
if those other factors
can co-vary as a chunk,
then maybe it's important to expose that
to say that actually if some of this
larger cognitive item changed or
this larger correlated item changed,
then actually the output
could be different. Um,
I think that comes back to
this accuracy tradeoff that I,
that I mostly said I'm
not going to worry about,
but it's this question of any form of
explanation is not going to be perfectly
faithful to your model.
Assuming that your model is some
really large complicated system.
And so that's going to have to be another
user defined threshold of like how,
how much accuracy am I willing
to sacrifice. Um, and you,
if you are not willing to sacrifice a
lot of accuracy and your explanations,
um,
you still need your explanations,
maybe they're going to suffer in quality
in the sense that maybe you are going
to have to include more things.
So all of this stuff I see in the setting
where you have a threshold on accuracy
and you say the explanation actually has,
has to be at least this good.
And given that the explanation is
this good, how can we limit, uh,
how can we make it more of higher quality?
So maybe the case that certain instructors
are easier for people to understand.
Um,
and it may be the case that like a can
be grounded in something that actually
consists of a lot of items and
maybe even this link from a to B.
If we are finding that it takes people
a lot of time to traverse things of a
certain length, but maybe it takes
people less time to traverse things,
have a shorter length, uh, or, or sorry,
the of things that they know that maybe
that effectively reduces the length,
right?
So here,
these are hypotheses to keep in mind
and as you're building your systems,
one thing you can think about is like,
since interpretability is
such a human concept, right,
we can't really think about it without
thinking about what is the language of
the human.
I think that's maybe the,
another key idea to keep in mind is
that we need to have like basically a
dictionary of what is the language of
the human to be thinking about this.
All right. Um, so I'm going
to say mostly rapid there. Um,
uh,
I'm the investigating these hypotheses
and these sorts of questions I think are
really important because they're
going to lead us to understand,
um, are there model classes? It seemed
to work well for certain settings.
So that was the first hypothesis was
a task Atherton and covariates, right?
So those are our settings.
And then are there model classes or
regularizes and maybe that has to do with
the forms of the structures that
we consider. Okay. Or not okay, um,
that are best for certain settings.
And these are a set of experiments
that we could do that we should do,
that we should be supporting each
other as a community, um, to do. Um,
because I think that until we really
get a solid sense of like the cognitive
science of explanation as it relates to
really specific machine learning tasks,
we're not going to be able to make
comparisons between different methods very
rigorously. And we also may end up just
optimizing the wrong things, right?
You may end up optimizing
for some form of, uh,
some function and find that it's not
actually the function that you needed to,
to do the task at hand.
Um,
so in terms of the big takeaways that
I want us to, to be thinking about,
and again, leaving plenty
of time for discussion, um,
the first is that when
do we need explanations?
So we need explanations when there's
a fundamental incompleteness and the
problem specification. And that's, and,
and it's important to be honest about
that because there's many cases where that
just doesn't happen, right? Like if
the system is operating independently,
does not need any humans, the problem as
well as specified as well as it can be,
then it's great to just throw
like a super predictive,
deep model at it. And that's
the best you can do. Right?
And it will and that that's
what you should do. Um,
so thinking about when do you
actually need explanation? Um,
and also this point,
there's a spectrum of valid evaluation
going from just like, you know,
what's my right, what's my l
one sparsity score to, uh, uh,
how well does it perform in a
particular embedded task setting? Um,
and to do this properly,
we're going to need more
connections it to cognitive science.
And my claim is that a relatively modest
effort in terms of doing some of these
experiments could have huge
payoffs because maybe we're
optimizing too much for
the wrong things. Where it, you, if
you have papers that say, you know,
I can get something that's five sparse
and somebody else can get something
that's forced bars, does it, is it
actually help? Right? Like, it was worth,
it was that extra effort worth it.
Um,
and maybe there's something completely
different that we should be focusing on
that we're missing out on because we
haven't thought about it. Um, so the,
the main thing that I want to encourage
us all to do is let's be rigorous about
this question of interpretability that
there's ton of research going on in this
area.
Um,
there's not really consensus on how to
evaluate it and how to think about it.
But as we go forward,
we're going to need to be able to make
decisions about which system is better
for a particular task and when,
when have we reached satisficing cause
interpretability I think is definitely
the sort of thing where you reach a
level where people can understand it and
once people can understand it,
then in some instances your task is done
because you've managed to communicate.
It's a cool, so I'll leave it at
that. Um, I'd love to hear questions,
opinions and discussion.
Thank you very much.
That was wonderful talk.
I think the connections with Congress
slants or just very fascinating and raise
lots of questions have one that can point.
Mine was we know that people are
very sensitive to framing effects.
The same information
presented two different ways.
It can be very different in
how understandable they are.
How do we control for that when we're
evaluating different model classes?
And does there need to be a, you know, a
little subfield of this or like, you know,
let's try to find the most best
framing for, you know, these,
these narrow networks or models.
Okay.
I think that's another
really important question.
And so I didn't really get into the,
like how do you set up the system that
provides the explanation and just also
just the more general Ui issue of how,
how you present this.
I envisioned it,
or like early experiments can probably
be done in sufficiently abstract settings
that you can try to control for as
much of these effects as possible.
But certainly in a real situation that's
going to be another access that needs
to be carefully discovered.
So it seems that there is a
inverse relationship between, uh,
the performance of a model and the
interpretability of that model.
So for example, logistic
regression is extremely simple. Uh,
doesn't often perform that
well. It does well, but, um,
but most importantly it's extremely
interpretable because each of the
coefficients in the model,
you can say, okay, this is a,
this is a big positive effect, but
this is a big negative effect. Uh,
whereas more complicated model is deep
model is they tend to be very hard to
interpret. Uh, do you think that
inverse relationship is inevitable?
Is,
is that,
is there a law saying that the better
model performs the more unintelligible it
becomes or you know, is there
some way or you know, around that?
I actually, I don't agree with that. Um,
there's so Cynthia Ruden quotes this
paper, which I'm forgetting, um,
that let's sees it many times there's
many models that perform reasonably well,
um, that, that oftentimes that
you can find multiple models.
And certainly our anecdotal evidence with
like training deep models is that you
can get multiple deep models that
produce similar predictive scores.
And the question is,
can you make some of those
more interpretable than
others by say involving fewer
dimensions?
So I would act.
And I also pushed back on the fact
that like it's something like logistic
regression interpreter wall because if
you've got 100,000 dimensions in your
logistic regression and they are covariate
and all sorts of funny ways that you
know, the top leader things
might mean nothing, right? And,
and so I actually don't agree with
the fact that it's simpler models,
simpler models like linear model,
like a linear model or generalized linear
model are actually more interpretable
than deep models. And once you're in
high dimensions, and one thing that,
one direction that I'm really excited
about in terms of avenues is this notion
of local interpretability is that is for
any particular explanation or instance
input. Can you provide me an explanation
that is succinct? And I think there,
there is hope even with deep
models because you can, um,
because it also with deep models you
can pick out intermediate layers, right?
You can think about the cognitive chunk.
So if you can identify a layer in the
network that largely activates when
there's a cat in the picture,
then you can say that the reason why
I've done this classification, um,
for, for this being like the
wizard of Oz as the, or, you know,
a scene from wizard of Oz is because I
see the lion here and at like I've picked
out the lion in the picture,
right?
Same thing with two things that we
have going for us is that we only,
we may only need to explain one instance
at a time and that we have access to a
lot.
We're kind of assuming that we have
access to a library of cognitive concepts.
And I think so there's,
there's absolutely hope for being able
to explain deep models or finding models.
Um,
it such that these properties are also
true and you don't have to sacrifice on
prediction.
You might also argue that if the model
is getting you tons more predictive
accuracy in a certain situation,
like I can't think of situations where
that would happen where you're not maybe
picking up like a weird confound,
right? Like, maybe you're at,
you're getting a load more accuracy,
but it's because you picked out some weird
correlation that maybe maybe it's not
true.
Yeah.
So it would seem like there's a difference
between experts and non experts in
terms of how explainable something is
where like the person who's flying the
plane every day knows exactly where to
look and what they're looking for and
they want to make the
decision really quickly.
Do you think that if the distinction
expert non-expert is enough or do we need
like gradations are experts in different
fields in terms of understanding how
these proxies would generalize to
other fields or other situations?
I think that's a great question.
And one of the thing,
so this is a hypothesis and empirical
thing that needs to be tested.
And I should say this is all
in discussion with being um,
Jesse Johnson here.
Sam Grossman.
I'm at Harvard where we've been talking
about like experiments and hypotheses.
We believe we are a hypothesis that we
think is testable is that there are still
fundamental aspects of like control
processes that humans can understand in
terms of this uh,
chains of causation or agents and
actors and that part and the difference,
the hypothesis is a difference
between experts and non experts.
My is not necessarily that the expert
can hold more in memory or a whole
different structures and memory,
although certainly people
get trained to do that.
So that's the thing that we could,
we should be absolutely aware of but
we're curious how far you can go with this
hypothesis that maybe experts
just have different chunks.
So we figured out like a
general structures that are
generally explainable and
then we can sub in
chunks that experts have,
cause the doctor might have a name for
something or a way of understanding a
particular device that somebody
else doesn't have access to.
And can we plug that in
and it's an open question.
Squeeze in one last question.
I wonder if there are fundamental,
the fundamental differences in the area
of interpretability between domains that
are deeply studied like healthcare
and domains that are brand new,
like how to maximize clicks
on ads, um, that the,
um,
the existence of a deep spectrum
of human expertise on the one hand,
um,
puts very different pressures on our
machine learning systems in that context.
It just to make sure I understand.
So you're saying that there are some
cases where there's a lot of domain
expertise,
um,
and there's cases where there is less
domain expertise in terms of what the
explanation would provide?
Yeah, absolutely. That you buy,
you might observe that a lot of the
most interesting applications of machine
learning recently have been in areas
that are not that deeply studied.
Whereas we've,
we've struggled to have equal
impact in healthcare, uh,
maybe because of the amount of, of,
of learning that's already happened.
So I, I think to, so there's the,
there's potentially the claim that
maybe there's a lot of learning that has
already happened in healthcare,
so maybe there's less to advance on.
I think it actually does come down
to this incompleteness and problems
specification that makes it
a lot of these real tasks,
harder real world task harder than tasks
that we have created like somehow human
created.
So like the click question is something
that's very closed in the form of we
have a system we can measure whether
something changes, click rates are not.
And so there's a way in which the problems
and so to the extent that you defined
the problem as we want to
increase certain rates, right?
It's very measurable and it can
be done in a closed loop fashion.
And I'm not sure if it
requires interpretability if
you're asking the question
more broadly,
if like uptake of machine learning or
like value provided by machine learning in
certain settings.
And I think it is entirely fair to say
that the value that machine learning is
added incentive settings where um,
the,
the problem is not fully specified.
And where there is this
incompleteness where you,
you're measuring things in the
EHR and the EHR, super messy, um,
has not necessarily been there because
we haven't really figured out how to
communicate and measure
in those systems.
Thank you.